[Music]
when you see someone weeping in sorrow
either because a child has gone on a
journey
or because he has lost his property
beware that
you be not carried away by the
impression that the man
is in the midst of external ills but
straight away keep before you this
thought
it is not what has happened that
distresses this man
for it does not distress another but his
judgment about it
do not however hesitate to sympathize
with him so far as words go
and if occasion offers even to groan
with him
but be careful not to groan also in the
center of your being
chapter 16 is a particularly important
section of the end caridian because what
it reveals to us
is the stoic approach to
other people's misfortune and
this actually goes to answering a
question that gets asked
quite a lot which is how should a stoic
approach other people having things
happen to them
that at least they see as bad in part
because
according to stoic doctrine what is in
our control
is what is good or bad what's outside of
our control
is an external is it indifferent it
might be preferred or rejected but it's
ultimately
without the same sort of moral value as
what does lie within our control
so you would think that the stoic would
spread that good
news in dealing with people who say are
grieving
or anxious or angry or
upset about different things and that's
not what epictetus tells us to do
so it's really quite important that we
look at what he
he does advice he says when you see
somebody
weeping in sorrow either because a child
has gone on a journey
or because he has lost his property some
something that
a lot of people would see as a real
calamity we could add a lot of other
things to this
some people get upset like that
when somebody you know breaks off a
relationship you know if they're
usually if they're the one who's dumped
but also if they're the one who
has to break it off when a job ends
um when uh the economy takes a down
turn when some people get get as upset
like that when their their sports team
loses particularly if it's in the
championships and they could have gone
all the way this year so
we see people weeping we see people
upset we see people
anxious we see people angry how should
we
respond to them then he says beware that
you
n be not carried away by the impression
by the fantasia the the appearance
that the person is in the midst of
external ills
but straight away keep before you the
thought and this is applying the thought
that we see in another chapter it is
not the things themselves that disturb
us
it's our judgments about the things we
then apply that
to another person and epictetus says
it's not what has happened that
distresses this this person
for it does not distress another like
for example me
right off the bat or somebody else in
similar circumstances
some people are fine when their kids go
off to camp some people are
a-okay when they lose their their
property some people
are you know quite all right when when
their job
ends and they have to figure out what to
do so it's
not what has happened that distresses
this person
but this person's judgment about it
what we can do is we as stoics we can
say
this not only applies to me but it
applies to everyone else who's a human
being
it's our judgments about things that
turn them into the big problems they are
oftentimes on the basis you know we have
an appearance
and then we make all sorts of
assumptions and inferences about it and
connect it with past experiences that we
have
and projections into the future our
fears and our desires
our aversions get bound up with it and
before long
we're very upset and we're convinced
that we're upset because
that external thing made us upset in
that way
often times it turns out that we're not
even on base about what that external
thing
is we're we're mistaken about it but
even if it is
the way it presents itself you know we
you find out you're gonna
you're gonna die of cancer right uh
there's ways of dealing with that
that don't require you to lose yourself
in
in grief right or if you do lose
yourself in grief to be able to bring
yourself
back from the brink of it and so he says
now you know that about yourself how do
you apply that to
another person who is another human
being like you
notice what epictetus doesn't say he
doesn't say
go and teach that person stoic
philosophy
straighten them out about what is in
their control or what's not in their
control
instead he says um
do not however hesitate
to sympathize with him as far as
words go and the the um term here in the
greek
is actually um
uh to the fairen means to carry or to
bear
and sum peri means think about like you
know wrapping your arms as we say
wrapping your arms around
a problem or wrapping your head around a
problem
you can embrace the other person you can
embrace their difficulties
as far as as he says as far as words
go or if you want to think about as far
as reason goes
uh mogu as far as reason goes
and he says if occasion offers
you can even groan with that person
again there's a soon construction with
right you
you sympathize with them by um
being there by listening
with them by saying yes it is unfair yes
it's a terrible thing but what epictetus
then says
afterwards that is the most important
counsel
is this be careful not to groan also
in the center of your being
don't allow that to get to you it's
quite possible to be sympathetic
or if you like empathetic or
compassionate
you know sometimes people get hung up on
these words they all basically amount to
the same thing
um it's possible to have this
comportment
towards other people in their
difficulties
in their their their uh failures
in the things that are happening to them
that they cannot help
but see as calamities they cannot help
but see as disasters that are befalling
them
even though they're mistaken about it
it's possible to be sympathetic
in words in action but without
committing oneself
to agreeing with them a lot of times
people
think that it's it's fundamentally
important that we agree
in an emotional way with with each other
and that's true
when we're agreeing about what's
actually correct
it's not important to agree with people
when they're wrong as a matter of fact
you're doing your self-harm
by agreeing with somebody who has a
mistaken perspective
and if they were in their right mind
they wouldn't want you to do that
if they were being rational they would
see that that's a bad thing
not only for themselves but for for you
that it's dragging you down along with
them
so this is something that that's quite
useful it shows us that
stoics are not uncompassionate cold
people but that they have a sort of
measured approach
to a world in which we're all vulnerable
to
disasters and calamities and
disappointments
remember that you are an actor in a play
the character of which is determined by
the playwright
if he wishes the play to be short it is
short if long
it is long if he wishes you to play the
part of a beggar remember to
act even this role adroitly and so if
your role be that of a [ __ ] an
official or a layman
for this is your business to play
admirably the role assigned you
but the selection of that role is in
others
i don't doubt that everybody who is
watching this
has heard at one time or another whether
from shakespeare or whether from a rush
song
that the whole world is a stage and we
are merely
players this is one of the origin points
of of that idea epictetus's end coridian
he says remember that you are an actor
a hupo crites the word that we get
hypocrite from
from the new testament right in a play
in a dramatos and he says the character
of which
uh is or what kind of play it is
is determined by the playwright
by the didaskalos by the person who
is teaching through the play
it's his choice it or her choice or
whatever his choice right
so we've got this idea that the the
whole cosmos
is really one vast play and we all have
our parts in it now he says
if the the playwright wishes the play to
be short it's short
if he wishes for it to be long it's long
if he now here's where it gets really
important because it has to do with us
if he wishes you to play the part of a
beggar
remember to act even this role adroitly
right if you're being assigned the role
of a beggar
you can play it and be you know ticked
off about
it and think that the whole world is
unfair and against you
or you can play it well what would that
mean playing it well
so that your moral faculty is in
accordance with nature so that you
fulfill the roles that you have towards
other people
so that you act with integrity and you
might say well how can you possibly act
with integrity
as a beggar well you know maybe don't
tell people that you're you're blind
when you're not blind right
it's not that that difficult and we can
say this about so many other things
and epictetus gives us a few examples he
says um
if your role is is that of a [ __ ] or
an official
or as he's got translated here a
layperson a non-philosopher an idiot
uh a person or idiots a person who
is is not getting the opportunity to
study or just
hasn't studied right and we could say
this in our own culture
about so many other things you know
you're a man you're a woman uh you're
going to be rich you're going to be poor
you're going to be
somewhere in between uh you're at one
point in your life
uh quite likely you're a student and
then at other points in your life you're
something else and we go through a lot
of career shifts
epictetus is not saying that you can't
move from career to career
with this right but those those are
different roles and perhaps your role
is a composite role that you're going to
play different aspects of
over time what he's saying is that we
should
play the role well we should do so
without complaining about it and he says
this is your business he says
sugar to testi this is yours this is
something
within your power if we're going to talk
about the dichotomy
between what is not in our power and
what is in our power
it's not in your power to choose what
role
you're actually given although that
doesn't mean that you wouldn't say
you know experiment around to see what
your role might might turn out to be
what you're well suited for what the
universe or
or you know the fate is telling you
is your your actual function
but once you've got it whether you play
it well or whether you do it poorly
that is up to you that is something in
your power
that means that playing your role well
is something good playing your role
poorly
is something bad because it is in your
power
so he says
the selection of the role is another's
if you get upset about the role that
you've been assigned
you're probably not going to play it
particularly well
if you think that you ought to have been
given the starring role
and you're constantly complaining about
that whatever supporting role you have
is not going to be particularly good we
want to use
music as an example think about a band
you know a rock band
where you have say two guitarists one is
a rhythm guitarist one is a lead
guitarist
you also have a bass player you also
have a drummer you also have a singer
right
let's say it's a five piece right and
if the rhythm guitarist says
how come i never get to play any solos
um
i you know i should get to solo just as
much as the lead guitarist
i'm not going to play these riffs
anymore how does it sound
does does it work well maybe the bassist
you know takes up the slack or
something like that or the the lead
guitarist has to you know
drop down into a rhythm position and now
the solos
aren't very good um what happens if the
uh
bass guitarist says i want to play
just the guitar line and i don't
actually want to play the bass line
or i don't want to cooperate with the
drummer there you know the whole thing
falls apart
we can say this about so many other
things as well
so many activities where which which end
up being dependent on
more than one person doing their their
part
if we do our roles correctly if we
do what's in our power
then things work out better all around
and we feel better
about what we're doing when a raven
croaks
inauspiciously let not the external
impression carry you away
but straightaway draw a distinction in
your own mind and say
none of these portents are for me but
either for my paltry body
or my paltry estate or my paltry opinion
or my children or my wife but for me
every portent is favorable if i so wish
for whatever be the outcome it is within
my power to derive
benefit from it
it was quite common in ancient times for
people to place some sort of trust
or even a sort of superstitious faith
in what epictetus is talking about here
in this chapter as
portents another word that we use for
that is omens
and there was a wide range of different
practices some of which were connected
with particular places like like oracles
some of which might be conducted by
wandering practitioners
some of which were just widespread some
of which were culturally based
and i'll give you some examples of those
in a moment
and all of these were relied upon
by people who believed in them or
weren't quite sure whether they believed
in them or not but kind of felt like
these
these things were meaningful as
signs about what the divine what the
god happened to think or gods happen to
think
and about what the future held for them
so epictetus is talking here about
how we should approach those those sorts
of matters notice that he's not actually
saying
there's nothing to it just ignore it all
together
you know perhaps if he was in our own
culture
that might be his response although
there's a lot of people who are very
superstitious about all sorts of things
along these sorts of lines in our own
culture today
and there's many people who do it in a
kind of
hazy you know more modern way
which doesn't necessarily talk in terms
of the gods but might talk in terms of
the cosmos
or karma or you know the
grand historical process or all sorts of
these sorts of things
the the main point is that people
thought that there were
signs available to them which then they
had to take into account
and one can have that sort of
orientation
about the economy uh about the stock
market
about one's job prospects one can
associate things that aren't necessarily
accurate predictors uh but but are very
striking
with you know the things that we are
concerned about
now the ancient romans had all sorts of
things they'd cut animals
open and take a look at their liver and
see what was going on with that
you know there was uh the flights of
birds and which way the birds were
circling or who they they landed on and
whether birds attacked each other
there were all sorts of things and if
you look at any given culture
you can usually find some things along
those lines we have lots of expressions
as well
that are now you know sort of worn out
metaphors but but
which originally conveyed some message
about that
so what is epictetus
telling us about these sorts of matters
he says when a raven croaks
inauspiciously okay so a ravenocorox is
a kind of black bird
and it was felt like you know maybe this
is conveying some sort of message
let not the external impression the
fontasia
carry you away literally grab on to you
and drag you
along but straight away now notice what
he says draw a distinction
in your mind make a distinction for
yourself
and say none of these portents are for
me they're not for what truly is
myself my faculty of choice my ruling
faculty
my rational faculty you know the things
that are the higher part of ourselves
that really are who we are our character
none of these
portents apply to that but instead they
apply
to and he uses this this term here uh
which is translated as paltry um
and that's sort of a rendering of what's
in the greek you know
somation in the dative somation would be
like a little body my own
little body or my own little
uh possessions uh
dion or my my own little
opinion or a better way of translating
it here would be
my own little reputation what it is that
people
think about me and now why is he talking
in the diminutive
well in part to to show the distance
between the self
what is truly oneself and these external
things that we are all too
often tempted to identify with the self
and to place
our good or evil in as opposed to
realizing that it lies within us
so he says those sorts of things
external things my body my estate my
opinion and notice what he also says
after that
or my children or my wife we might
extend this to
or my friends or my social media
presence
or my parents you know all of those
things
you know we feel like we can get damaged
we feel like we're vulnerable
in those those matters but they're
really outside of ourselves
and so if the raven is crowing
inauspiciously it might be growing
inauspiciously for those things
maybe the gods actually do send signs
that say up you're going to get boils on
your body
or oh your your marriage is going to
break down or oh your child is going to
die or run away or tell you what what a
terrible parent you are
that they hate your guts or any any one
of these sorts of things oh you're going
to lose your job
oh you know that's not
something that the raven is saying about
you that's something the raven is saying
about
those external things and so
if we make this distinction then we
won't be so upset
by the ambiguous signs that we're
getting these signs that seem to
threaten
us he says for me every portent
is favorable if i so wish
for whatever be the outcome it is within
my power
to derive benefit from it what he's
saying here
is is very important notice there's two
parts there
for me every important not only is
something i could ignore
but it's actually favorable even if it's
something about how my body
is going to have something bad happen to
it i mean you might think
you know for example uh about the role
that webmd
plays in in our internet age uh in
examining the things that are happening
to our body
oh my god i've got this blemish here i
hope it's not
cancer i'll go and look it up that's
acting in a very
superstitious way and and maybe it is
maybe you know uh you don't misinterpret
the webmd
thing and you really do find out that
you're likely
going to have cancer and so now you go
to the doctor and you're sitting there
in your hospital gown you know
doctor comes in and gives you the bad
news i'm very sorry to say
but but you have cancer a stoic would
say my body has cancer
i have the choice about how i'm going to
deal
with the cancer i
have the capacity to decide whether this
is going to be
indifferent and whether i'm going to
face up to it with integrity
or whether i'm going to view this as a
total calamity or
or something in between that's up to me
and so what what he's saying here goes
beyond just merely withdrawing and
saying oh that's nothing to me
epictetus is saying everything can be
turned
to good use and remember that use
crisis in the greek use of external
things
is in fact something that lies within
our power
is in fact something that is either good
or bad
depending on how we use it it is
something that
falls within the scope of our faculty of
choice
so this is a very important affirmation
that he's giving us here at the end
we don't have to be afraid of the
threatening signs that we see on the
horizon
if we can learn to dissociate the things
that
are vulnerable to the processes that
those signs might be signifying
from what really does lie within
our own control what really is us
you